your family is the epitome of fabulous
thank you and what we've seen I think
especially with your older girls is that
there's a real understanding of the word
privilege and especially Aoki I love
following her on today yes shout out to
Aoki shout out Aoki she's my feisty one
stop beating around the bush I know that
I benefit from nepotism in modeling and
fashion hugely right my parents don't
get my jobs I don't believe in that but
I benefit from their name their success
the privilege I've grown up with like
countless things and I'm well aware of
that what are those conversations that
you have with your kids about having so
much privilege I'm like any mom I fuss
at them they're not doing enough they
could be doing more
why don't you have a job she reminds me
you know I have many
she you know also is starting to model
so she's like hey I have a job
um or they'll tell me Mom we're going to
school you told us as long as we went to
school got good grades we were
respectful
that was our job and I said okay so
these are all good points yes that's a
full-time job in and of itself being a
student at NYU being a student at
Harvard but I want more and they know it
and they give it okay and that's the
point to whom much is given much is
expected so they know whether it's from
the littler kids like if you get a new
gift then you should give a gift because
you have you know a toy and a toy out
um that's a good policy yeah recycling
clothes it could be something simple
something that you think is so not cool
anymore I wore it already this many
times someone else that's the biggest
and best thing they've ever seen the
brightest thing they've ever seen in
their life
um so they know and I have this concept
that I've talked about a lot throughout
my life which is that I don't want to
raise kids that are a-holes and point
blank and then they're not they're good
kids they're beautiful kids you know we
have a wonderful crazy mixed tribe
they're all busy but they it's just
something that's been instilled in them
since they were born you know mingle say
she walks down the street in New York IO
people say she walks down the street in
Boston and the people will wave or
they'll come give you a hug and
sometimes they're a little frightened
and I'm like you have to understand like
people think you're their cousin or they
grew up with you or they grew up with
you on TV like now you're 22 they
remember you from when you were we
watched you grow up literally yeah all
of these things are very
small price to pay for being given you
know something so great so they know
um inherently that that's kind of like
their job god-given job god-given talent
to make someone else happy do you follow
Aoki on on Tick Tock I do she's a little
feisty and I own a great way yes I
believe that I always say are you too
feisty okay you better watch it and what
if someone comes with the opposing view
and it's like too much heat you know
what she said to me Mom since when have
I not been feisty yes I can take a
little Heat
and I wrote facts she's okay that's it
yeah I you know I want to get this right
she made a video about being called a
quote nepo baby and she was unpacking
the good and the bad that comes with
that nepotism is often a huge problem
especially when it boxes out people who
don't have that privilege but are as or
more qualified than people who are
getting the opportunities how does that
make you feel sometimes I'm a little
worried so in my household I'm always
like yelling like is that okay is that
too see-through is that too short to
piss off the wrong person and they're
all like Mom are you going soft on us
because this is not like the same queen
of fabulosity this is not the Kimora we
we grew up yes but the feistiness but I
think in my life that's what we do we
have you know
drama they're ready she's like bring it
on but it makes you very proud it makes
me very uh proud and happy that she can
show both sides it makes me feel really
warm inside that I raised her the right
way and you know I'm a I'm a single mom
and when people say oh your kids are so
this and that and you guys I'm like
you've got me guys we guys Me Myself and
I
um not to say that they don't have other
influences in their life of course but
to say that all of these things just
make for a well-rounded like person it
sets the stage for her for her future in
such an amazing way and now now it's so
wild because you know I I grew up
watching you revering you and then to
see your daughters stepping into your
shoes they're now pursuing modeling in
the entertainment industry can you
believe it I can your genetics I did not
was not expecting that really what were
you dissuading them yes hi I'm not
supposed to tell you that today Yoki was
like don't go there and say that but I
was why
ayoki is really hardcore into modeling
whereas meaning I think is a little bit
more of an influencer type less a
straightforward model I've experienced
so much since I was 12 years old I've
been in this business we didn't have you
know me too back in the day we didn't
know about a lot of things that we know
now we didn't have the rights we didn't
have the wherewithal when I say we I
mean women young women people of color
you name it we didn't have all of these
things that the kids kind of have now so
if I didn't if I I wouldn't choose it
for her if I had to push you into
something of a career
and a lot of times people say you know
but you went to Harvard and then
why would you go and model now and
sometimes I'm like yeah yeah but then on
the other side I'm like wait a minute
well why wouldn't she she's allowed to
have aspirations you're allowed to have
aspirations you're allowed to have fun I
think a lot of times they weren't we
weren't expected to have it all like who
said you could have brains and Beauty
you said you could go to Harvard and
also walk down a Runway well we're
telling you that that's what we're doing
here and there was a time also where we
all know because we've grown up we've
grown up in the public light that ayoki
was very shy very much a Wallflower when
she first started her social media she
wouldn't even show her face and now
she's telling people what the business
is yeah you know we're business women
too that's what's underneath it all
don't let the beauty of sheep of her
confuse you yeah we're business women
yeah I have an Empire I'm turning over
to my kids and gotta make sure they can
run it yeah run that and and they
support me and I support them and it
doesn't matter what you look like but
you look great but it matters what's up
here and that's something that no one
can take away from you but hey while
you're 20 and beautiful and you look
like a beautiful butterfly go right go
model as they're navigating that what
have you told them best advice you told
them and as you're now going through it
with these different eyes what are you
learning about what they're experiencing
I tell them things like my mom told me
like don't accept any wooden nickels
which means like big be care beware of
people's phoniness and their phony
intentions be real to yourself stay true
to yourself everything that's you know
Glitters Is Not Gold I try to teach them
things like that but also have fun
a lot I mean you know I thought Yoki was
going to be we thought she was going to
be like an archaeologist or a professor
or something like that you were like
please study archeology don't go into
modeling but then she said but then she
said well mom then you have to support
me forever because I'll be a teacher so
she'll need some family coin and I
thought talk about privilege I'm not
supporting you forever girl who
supported me forever me myself and I so
yeah we you could be an archaeologist
but you have to be a businesswoman too
and if modeling is is half of that you
know and there's a lot of girls doing a
lot of things that are
it could be worse you were born on the
runway so I guess it's you know it's my
fault except accept it I will and I'm
there every step of the way I'm the mom
that was crying on TV when they
blow-dried their hair the first time I
saw it I'm there every step of the way
and people know that yes well nobody
better cross those girls yeah hey let's
give it up for Miss Kimora guys let's go
we came here
to find some food trucks um school
supplies we know that it's like a crazy
time of year for everybody to get back
to school
time for Paris it's crazy Time for Kids
the work that you're doing with the boys
and girls club is just so wonderful tell
me why it's not only important for you
to get involved but for you to impart
that on all five of your kids all my
life I've been giving back so it's kind
of a selfish concept if you would
because so much joy comes out of that
very rarely do I even want to show up
anywhere unless it's like giving back I
don't want to talk on the phone unless
I'm
you know begging someone for money for
someone else I'm very good at that but
when I'm giving it to the kids oh I'm
Relentless my family my kids I know it's
like cliche but like to whom much is
given much much more is expected so to
be able to yeah bring them some Joy get
them ready to be able to give them
school supplies they can go back with
like a little confidence like Feeling
Fabulous any little thing that can make
it better
go over a little smoother and send our
kids off thank gosh they're going back
but send our kids off with a little more
confidence and a little more you know a
little Brighter Smile yeah it's a win
the highlight of my life
[Music]